[Music]
my name is Alexandra Wilson I am an
associate editor at Forbes primarily
editing the under 30 list so this is a
year-long project we have reporters in
the field working in their industries
constantly looking for the next
up-and-coming entrepreneurs we also have
an open nomination process so truly
anyone can nominate themselves or anyone
else this is a long process first the
reporters that are editing the category
will nominate a couple individuals to
become the callout honoree
then we'll go through those will push
back we'll ask for more and eventually
the final decision is made by Forbes
magazine the chief content officer and
Elaine so each category has an a-list
panel of judges and these are people
that are the top of their field they're
CEOs their founders their venture
capitalists they're individuals that are
constantly interacting with these types
of companies and really know what it
takes to succeed so we have ten
categories in Europe and there's one
individual per each category that is
meant to serve as a face that is unless
they're twin entrepreneurs and then it's
kind of hard to split them up so it's
really unique about the Europe list is
we have everyone gather in one spot in
one day and do a big photo shoot with
all ten of the call-outs and this is the
only list we do that for and it really
makes it pop and really special and it's
one of the most exciting days of the
year perhaps the best reaction that's
ever happened is someone that was a call
out a couple years ago they were on the
social entrepreneurs list and they had a
sort of trebled relationship with their
father he never really understood what
he was doing and he was disappointed
that he never graduated college and he'd
always planned to get his son a very
nice watch when he graduated college but
that didn't happen he went on to you
know found a toy company that taught
kids how to code and so once he made the
under 30 list just appeared in Forbes
magazine it was the first time his
father really understood what he did and
so he could finally bought him that
watch engraved with Forbes 30 under 30
and the date I did not get a watch out
of that but when I finally I met him
again in New York a couple years later
and he took off his watch and it was a
really special moment
[Music]